you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up
fresh calls for a windfall tax on oil
and gas giants as bp announces record
profits
india's power grid buckles under the
strain of an historic heat wave how can
the region adapt to the new normal
and how strapping face masks to cows
might help reduce the most potent
greenhouse gas emissions
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and reports on the race for
solutions now they're announcing calls
today for a windfall tax on energy
company profits to help alleviate the
cost of living crisis soaring oil and
gas prices saw bp profits nearly 5
billion pounds in the first three months
of this year their best performance in
over a decade but the government has
ruled out a one-off tax our climate
change correspondent hannah thomas peter
reports
as prices rise at the pump so do profits
for oil and gas companies
bp announcing a bumper first quarter
reigniting calls for a windfall tax to
help with the growing cost of living in
crisis
but the prime minister is resisting
concerned that easing pain today could
cause problems tomorrow if you put a a
windfall tax on uh on the energy
companies what that means is that you
discourage them from making the
investments that we want to see that
will in the end keep energy prices lower
for everybody bp's ceo unsurprisingly
agrees the message he's pushing it's not
just investments in renewable energy on
the line these are profits that are then
rewarding our shareholders who by the
way are not some faceless institutions
but pretty much anyone who has a pension
or pays into a pension in the uk is
affected by that
it has been an extraordinary period for
bp it lost 19 billion pounds after the
war in ukraine forced it to offload
shares in the russian state oil company
rosneft
but because of high oil and gas prices
underlying profits soared to 4.9 billion
pounds in the first quarter of this year
more than double the year before
the companies also promised to invest 18
billion pounds in green and fossil fuel
energy in the uk by the end of the
decade this company and others like it
often point out that it was just a few
years ago they were suffering record
losses because of the pandemic and that
it's not reasonable to face extra
taxation every time they do well but
campaigners and critics say that the
fossil fuel industry simply cannot be
trusted to do the right thing of its own
accord whether that's investing in clean
green energy or helping ease the
financial pressures on ordinary people
that's why labour wants to take the
money now rather than hope for it down
the line
a windfall tax only hits those profits
that the oil and gas companies didn't
expect to make and therefore it doesn't
affect their other investments it's a
practical way to help millions of people
with their energy bills it's labor's
proposal the government has got no
answer corporate freedom versus the
acute needs of millions being pushed
towards fuel poverty
for the government an uncomfortable
balancing act and possibly a moment of
political peril
hannah thomas peter sky news in central
london
well let's get some of the day's other
climate news now and scotland's
environment watchdog has asked
businesses to save water as they warn
that the country could face a shortage
this summer a lack of rainfall over
april and march
means it was drier than the usual winter
which could lead to water shortages now
the scottish environment protection
agency says businesses such as farms
should plan ahead to minimise water
usage and trickle irrigation on their
land to avoid wasting water
now thousands of people have evacuated
from their homes in new mexico as the
state battles the largest active
wildfire in the u.s the calf canyon fire
is moving quickly because of hot dry and
windy conditions and has already
scorched almost 50 000 hectares of land
now scientists warn wildfires will start
earlier and become more frequent as
climate change dries out and soil turns
to vegetation into kindling
and sea levels in some parts of new
zealand are rising twice as fast as
previously thought
climate researchers nzc rise found that
parts of wellington will see 30
centimeters of sea level rise in just 18
years time now this would cause
typically once in a century floods every
year globally sea levels are expected to
rise by at least half a meter by 2100
okay well an unreleasing heat wave
across south asia has pushed electricity
demand to a record high in india in
april and it's led to power cuts across
the country and
has forced india to import more coal
which powers about three quarters
of the country's electricity grind now
energy demand has spiked largely because
of the need of for air conditioning to
cool a sweltering population now in the
long term experts say heat waves will
only become more extreme so how can more
than a billion people adapt to those
difficult conditions well rika kosler is
research director of oxford university's
india center for sustainable development
and she is an expert in calling thanks
so much for joining us so my first
question radika is how do you go about
cooling down a billion people that
doesn't rely on fossil fuels
yeah thanks so building energy solutions
are not only based on fossil fuels
there's a long history of being able to
cool bodies and the built environment
using what are called passive cooling
measures these are usually deeply
integrated into the belt environment so
for instance the the use of heat
protection or
shading heat modulation or having thick
buildings um and then heat dissipation
for instance using natural ventilation
using evaporative cooling these are all
mechanisms that have been within
cultures and different geographies for a
long time and lifestyles are also an
important part of how one can keep cool
without using an air conditioner of
course depending on the severity of the
heat
i suppose radica people will say those
traditional methods of trying to cool
down so
starting meetings and working early in
the morning um
using even headscarf i know in the north
of india headscarfs are a big thing
because it takes the heat out of the
body but these traditional methods have
their limits
that's right these traditional methods
do have their limits and that is why
having active cooling alongside which
the dominant technology for is the vapor
compression based air conditioner so
that's the air conditioner that you know
is in most homes and offices
does need to be used when there is
extreme heat but air conditioners can
also be run at their optimal
level which is not the case right now so
for instance the energy efficiency of an
air conditioner can be of the highest
available standard in the market right
now most air conditioners that are being
used are not even at half the level of
energy efficiency that they could be and
similarly the refrigerants that air
conditioners use can be of um of of a
manner that has the least greenhouse gas
potential
than a lot of the current refrigerants
that are being used
i had a friend who told me that the heat
conditions in delhi are
unbearable and that means not even
taking a walk without being in a car
with air conditioning on those are
climate issues that are playing out
aren't they how do you think india
really needs to adapt and how soon do
they have to make those changes
well it's a multi-pronged strategy um
air conditioning is here to stay because
it is the dominant technology and
therefore the electricity that is
supplying that air conditioning load
needs to be renewable based um the
refrigerants that air conditioners use
need to be of low greenhouse gas
potential and passive design measures do
need to be integrated into the built
environment there is a lot of
construction
that is still taking place in india
passive cooling measures could be
integrated into that ensuring
ventilation ensuring shading ensuring
access to green public spaces and water
spaces it has to be a combination of
these different strategies both using
active cooling energy and using passive
measures
okay rika koshler thank you very much
for joining us on the daily climate show
well stopping climate change is all
about reducing emissions and the search
for solutions is becoming ever more
creative with livestock responsible for
up to 14 of global emissions of methane
the most potent greenhouse gas one
company has come up with an innovative
if somewhat bizarre solution take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
and also understanding the enormous
impact that reducing emissions in in the
cattle industry and particularly methane
emissions could have for our future and
for our planet
[Music]
i grew up
sharing a lot of time on my family farm
in the outskirts of the argentinian
pampas
but later pursued a career in design
technologies so
my background to tackle this particular
challenge was quite unique
the way that we reduce emissions uh from
cattle is through a wearable device and
essentially what the technology does is
it captures the methane that the animals
emit about 95
of the methane that the animals emit is
coming from the nostrils so what we do
is with this product
that is a smart cattle harness
we collect the methane that the animal
emits from the nostrils
and we convert it into carbon dioxide
and water vapor which is a process
called oxidation that greatly reduces
the global warming potential of myth
animations so it can have a tremendous
impact on the warming capacity of
methane as a greenhouse gas
do stay with us coming up
i'll be joined by lecturer in
international relations at cardiff
university jen allen and director of the
conservatives environment network sam
hall will be discussing the pros and
cons of a windfall tax and whether
rising sea levels in new zealand might
help in the search for solutions
elsewhere
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news let's get
straight to discussing some of those
climate issues with a lecturer in
international relations at cardiff
university jen allen and sam hall
director of the conservative environment
group hello to both of you
so the first question then bp's record
profits in the first three months of
this year have led to renewed calls for
a windfall tax on the massive profits
made by oil and gas companies it's an
emotive subject especially when
consumers are facing rocketing bills jen
let's start with you why do you support
a winful tax
there's a long-standing historic role
for governments to protect people from
the volatilities of markets uh this goes
back since before world war one and so
this is the clearest case we've seen of
international market volatility
affecting people in their homes in a
profound sharp way
since well probably at least this
generation
so
there's a clear call there's a clear
rule for the government to protect
people from when
markets change because of nothing that
anyone did you know bp in oil companies
this isn't the result of their
investments it's not the result of any
innovations
this money simply landed on their
doorstep because putin invaded ukraine
so there's a clear case here to help
protect people from
the implications of the war in ukraine
sam what would you say to
introducing a windfall tax then
well i'm skeptical in principle of a
windfall tax and the main reason is that
the transition to net zero is going to
be very capital intensive we're going to
need to massively scale up our wind our
solar our green hydrogen production in
order to meet our climate targets and
that's going to require a lot of private
sector investment and to unlock that
investment at lowest possible cost of
capital we need policy and investor
stability i fear that a windfall tax
will deter that investment create an
uncertain and unstable regulatory
environment for energy companies now i
would acknowledge that um these profits
are very high that we've seen from bp
and expect to see from shell and so far
we've not yet seen the desired response
from them in terms of pledges to
increase their investment in clean
energy
and i think unless we see in the coming
days bp and others uh increase their
plans for renewable investment or at
least signal that that's coming i think
the political pressure on on the
government to introduce such attacks is
going to get very hard to resist sam
there will be people watching this
evening who will be thinking that bp are
walking away with profits in excess and
they'll be looking at their energy bill
that comes in
in the few next few weeks and and
they'll be confused as to why they're
not getting more help what do you think
bp and other larger companies should do
with their profits then if not to help
customers
well so i mean i think there's a a role
for government here to provide
additional support for people in fuel
poverty to help with the increased costs
of energy and i think the support that's
already been set out isn't sufficient
and the government's going to need to
look at that again in the upcoming
budget in the autumn i also think the
government could go further on energy
efficiency and to help people insulate
their homes reduce their gas goals make
it cheaper to heat their home there was
some progress on that in the spring
statement with a cut to vat to make
insulation cheaper and but there's much
more to do particularly for fuel poor
households so i think there's a
definitely a role for government in
making more support available to people
to manage this cost i think the key
challenge for oil and gas companies and
energy companies more generally is
getting on with building cheap clean
energy projects you know we know that
the cause of higher energy bills is our
reliance on gas we need to transition
quickly away from gas get more cheap
onshore renewables onto the grid sooner
and i think that's where oil and gas
companies can really play a role in
investing in those cheap clean solutions
jen is that good enough
well i think it's everything that we do
need we do need more energy efficiency
we do need to support people to insulate
their homes we need the cheapest form of
energy to be dominating our grid and
that's wind
we need all of those things but right
now there's an obvious way to pay for it
and that is a short
unprecedented once in a generation type
of intervention and the windfall tax can
do that it's not a long-term solution
but it can help fund what we're looking
to fund and it can help protect people
from the market right now uh people are
looking at their energy bills and
they're worried what will happen in the
autumn when the temperatures aren't
quite as nice as we're seeing now so i
think we need to seriously look at this
option because their future investments
that 18 billion that bp is promised
that's in the budget that's already
spent so a windfall tax won't affect
that investment in the future
but not acting does send a signal that
they can continue to earn money off the
backs of the poor
sam is it a case of not rocking the boat
when it comes to this windfall tax
making sure that those oil companies
feel safe to operate here in the uk
well i'd agree that uh it's very
unlikely that we'd see a scaling back of
investment plans if there was to be a
windfall tax um as as the ceo of bps
confirmed today i think that the
question for me is uh are we going to
see further ambition on clean energy
investments and as i said i hope that
oil companies will react to the
political pressure that we're seeing now
for this windfall tax and voluntarily
choose to make those investments uh in
order to unlock the the cheap clean
energy that we need i think that's a
final point in this is that i think the
uk
really wants to be a global leader in
this green industrial revolution we want
to be the most attractive place for
companies to invest to create jobs and
so on i i fear that having
this sort of uh one-off tax which is not
predictable uh which wasn't uh planned
in advance could deter that investment
make us a less attractive place to
invest i think we'll only get popular
support for this agenda if we make the
uk a really attractive place for energy
investors okay sam jen stay with us uh
more to come on that story but we're
moving on uh to another subject uh and
when we think of countries threatened
from rising seas we often imagine don't
we small south pacific islands with few
resources but news this week that sea
levels are rising faster than expected
in new zealand means that that country
will need to put serious adaptation
plans into place and fast um sam i'll
start with you is this a wake-up call
for new zealand because as i said we
often think about those small far-off
pacific islands uh having this problem
i think it is a wake-up call for new
zealand and indeed for other wealthier
richer countries about the the imminent
threats of climate change when it's
talked about in the media often climate
change is seen as this potential thing
that's predicted by models that's going
to happen to us in the future rather
than now and something that happens
elsewhere in other places in more
vulnerable countries like those small
pacific islands you mentioned and i
think this this story uh you know we can
read across the uk where we know that
coastal communities in the east coast
and south coast of england and elsewhere
are also going to face rising sea levels
and you know i think we are well behind
on our adaptation planning it gets less
emphasis than than the mitigation side
and i think uh hopefully this is a
wake-up call that we need to do more in
terms of sea defenses natural solutions
like uh coastal realignments as well in
order to make sure we're prepared for
the climate change that is already baked
in um
okay sam indeed uh jen i guess what it
shows us doesn't it is that
nobody no country no nation is immune
from climate change least of all new
zealand
yeah climate change it's here it's now
it's happening and no one is immune uh
what varies is that some countries will
be able better able to adapt than other
countries so
small island states developing countries
they're already facing the effects of a
warmer world whether it's droughts or
floods or sea level rise
they can't adapt in the same ways or
build the resilience in the same ways
that new zealand will be able to and so
the solutions that new zealand comes up
with the solutions that the uk comes up
with uh you know in wales we're already
looking at sea level rise around average
with
so
what we can do as
the luckier countries essentially that
can start to look at this adaptation is
figure out how we can scale that up and
how we can help other countries in a
meaningful way to adapt to the climate
change that they're already experiencing
sam mate jen makes a really good point
there doesn't she that this situation in
new zealand will potentially help the
world have solutions to dealing with
rising sea levels and i guess it has
implications for here in the uk because
there are various reports aren't there
from climate scientists that say rising
sea levels across
the british coast could see
flooding in 2030
absolutely i think there's a
huge opportunity for um developed
nations to develop some of the solutions
and to be able to export them i think
there's also a need for developed
nations to deliver on their climate
finance promises as well and to help
developing countries with less access to
finance uh to uh to invest in some of
these solutions and i think that's we're
going to be a big focus in uh in egypt
cop27 um i mean in terms of the uk and
our adaptation planning i think there's
a lot more that we need to do i think if
you look at the
the government focus that you get i
think you see much bigger focus on
mitigation there's a whole climate
change minister within days and whereas
client adaptation is a small bit of
someone's brief within defra you get
twice uh you get a report every year on
mitigation from the climate change
committee and government response it's
only once every two years on adaptation
and so you know across government i
think this needs to be much more focused
on this and i think simply also from
climate campaigners and the climate
movement um i think i think often focus
on mitigation because you know they want
to try and uh see as little climate
change as possible and fear that a focus
on adaptation lets people off the hook
on mitigation i think the reality is we
need to do both urgently
and we can't we can't ignore either
i can see that jen's nodding in
agreement there we'll end this
discussion here jen and sam thank you
very much for your insights
today well that's all from us for now
but do stay with us because coming up
common ground trevor phillips and his
guests will discuss i thought it's right
that russian players should be banned
from wimbledon
[Music]